pour en parler justement de cette
conférence de sargueil la preuve avec
nous sur ce plateau gérard vespière
chercheurs la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient et auteur du site
le monde décrypté pan comme monsieur
vesper bonjour bonjour vous merci d'être
avec nous et justement on va décrypter
avec vous cette conférence annuelle de
sergueï lavrov des sessions en sommes
voilà une session de questions réponses
sargal à vanves a répondu à toutes les
questions des journalistes
internationaux le prisme étaient très
larges conflit iranien libyen liberté
d'expression a débuté par évoquer les
conflits actuels trop nombreux
malheureusement il ya celui de la syrie
où la russie a joint un véritable rôle
de médiateur sergueï lavrov l'art audi
priorité à la poursuite du processus
politique
on en est où justement de ce côté là
alors c'est une vision très important
parce que assez ma mémoire est bonne à
l'armée russe est intervenu en syrie le
30 septembre 2015 et donc quelques
semaines après il était décidé de nommer
alexandre lavrentiev comme étant le
responsable des discussions dans le
cadre du projet syrien est donc assez
rapidement ensuite en 2018
à
valet le président poutine a déclaré le
règlement devra être politique et toutes
les armées étrangères devant quitter le
terrain et donc alexandre la frontière
48 heures après a dit les armées
iraniennes y compris donc il y a un très
grand effectivement une très grande
démarche à construire en syrie le départ
de l'armée turque le départ des forces
iraniennes
le départ des forces américaines donc
c'est un véritable challenge à effectuer
pour retrouver une scierie à peu près
reconstruite au moins deux points de vue
militaire et territoriales sariel avant
a même parlé de deux priorités en série
à la poursuite du processus politique on
vient de parler et la lutte contre le
terrorisme
les deux vont de pair n'est ce pas will
faso sont effectivement deux points
importants à puisque s'il ya encore
présence d'éléments terroristes n'ira
pas d'unité apolitique et même une unité
territoriale donc il faut effectivement
alors dans l'été russie à deux volets le
volet disons des rebelles contre le
pouvoir de damas et puis des shows qui
est sur une autre planète donc il y a
deux je dirais deux foyers à surveiller
de très près alors sergueï lavrorv l'a
redit il ya cette initiative heureuse de
la sécurité collectif dans le golfe
persique est ce que la russie en tout
cas à proposer un mécanisme commun de
sécurité dans le golfe
est-ce que c'est faisable à l'heure
actuelle alors c'est une un projet qui a
déjà été abordé par les états unis a
même sous la présidence actuelle en 2017
le président a le précédent ministre de
la défense
un matisse avait lancé l'idée du mesa
middle-east strategic alliances et
donkey kong contenait dans cette
alliance la jourdanie les gîtes l'arabie
saoudite le qatar dont voyez vous donc
déjà ce mouvement qui avait été lancée à
qui était rediscuter encore il ya peu de
temps à mec qui ne se matérialise pas
vraiment donc je pense que ça relève
d'un d'aveux
maintenant il ya une telle tension
actuellement que cela devient je crois
difficile avec les tensions à
l'intérieur de l'irak avec les tensions
à l'intérieur du liban lors sergueï
lavrov a fait référence bien évidemment
à la réunion de moscou qui s'est tenue
il ya quelques jours
khalifa haftar et est fayez al sa rage
était là-bas moscou mais les deux hommes
ne se sont pas rencontrés ils ont refusé
de se voir comme le disait sergueï
lavrov dont une situation très tendue en
libye
dans un tel contexte où des parties
prenantes au conflit refuse de s'asseoir
à la table des pourparlers
comment on peut aboutir et messieurs
politique comme est souhaitée comme
c'est souhaité par la russie en tout cas
il faut signer une fois d'après fo si
une deuxième fois il faut signer une
troisième fois à je pense que la
résolution à ne peut se passer qu'au
autour du tapis vert à il n'est pas
question que à tripoli ton militairement
a je pense que les forces du général
naresh à la star ne sont pas suffisantes
pour cela je pense que la population non
plus n'est pas prête et que les milices
qui sont sur le terrain ne se laisseront
pas sortir de tripoli donc il faut aller
à la réunion à la conférence à au tapis
vert pour que nous puissions avoir un
début de début de solution la conférence
internationale sur la libye on le
rappelle qui aura lieu ce dimanche à
berlin
on part alors d'issue politique pourtant
il ya peu hard ouanna a décidé de
déployer des troupes militaires en libye
pour venir en aide a failli à sa rage
laisse pas une action qui pourrait
justement remettre en cause tous ces
efforts diplomatiques qui sont déployés
en ce moment alors effectivement je
pense que là
l'intervention a duré que rend les
choses un peu plus compliquée et elle
est liée à des liens politiques à de la
proximité à des frères musulmans avec le
gouvernement officiel de tripoli et la
proximité des frères musulmans et de
pouvoir en quarts a donc c'est avant
tout une proximité idéologique et
politique qui a créé cette intervention
et si on regarde les choses de près à ce
ne sont pas vraiment des soldats turcs
qui sont intervenus mais ce sont des
milices syrienne formé par les turcs
avec du matériel turcs mais je pense que
la turquie reste très prudent alors
justement vladimir poutine et à
volodimir zelensky se sont réunis à
paris c'était au mois de décembre
ils ont entériné une série de mesures
pour relancer le processus de paix en
ukraine où en est actuellement ce
processus il suit son cours je pense
qu'effectivement il était nécessaire
après le président je dirais de la
séparation qui était prochaine qu il y
avait besoin d'un renouvellement à à
kiev pour que le dialogue puisse se
renouer entre kiev et moscou
c'est effectivement l'arrivée de
volodymyr zelensky qui avec la volonté
deuxièmement le changement
d'interlocuteur a permis de commencer un
dialogue et donc la libération de
prisonniers qui va se poursuivre à le
cessez le feu a l'air de progresser donc
on est dans la bonne direction alors
très rapidement on va parler un du
conflit etats unis iran qui prend un peu
une autre tournure un ca dernières
semaines alors ça égaye labro va parler
de l'attitude des européens qui seraient
sous pression de washington ne trouvez
vous pas justement à l'attitude de
l'union européenne un peu tiède un peu
frileux sur ce dossier l'attitude de
l'union européen a toujours été très
clair le président de la république et
angela merkel et le
londres ont toujours été sur la même
ligne à savoir l'accord actuel un point
faible à savoir ce qu'on appelle la
saône cette clause à dire 2025
c'est très bientôt parce que les choses
vont vite à il n'y a rien de prévu après
2025 donc commençons à en parler
maintenant
deuxièmement le programme balistique qui
ne fait pas partie de l'accord nucléaire
est un souci pour tout le monde à la
frontière russe est à 1200 km de terrain
on espère donc le balistique concerne
tout le monde
et troisièmement les interventions
systémique de téhéran dans les affaires
libanaises dans les affaires syriennes
dans les affaires irakiennes
ce soir on l'a vu un très récemment et
puis aussi au yémen
donc l'ensemble de ces trois dossiers
selon les européens nécessite une à
nouveau des contacts méthodique qui
suivit avec téhéran
très rapidement est ce que une issue
diplomatique peut encore arriver entre
l'iran les états unis
oui c'est nécessaire il faudra passer
par là il n'y ait pas de de crise qui
n'est pas à jour connu un aboutissement
donc c'est ou bien le peuple iranien se
soulève et aboutit un changement du
régime
ce qui pourrait à ce moment-là
redistribuer complètement les cartes en
iran et bien sûr dans la région ou bien
le pouvoir actuel vient la table de
négociations merci gérard vespière
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
chercheur à la fondation d'études pour
le moyen-orient et auteur du site le
monde décrypté par com merci bonne
journée